hey everyone my name is Daniel ila I'm
one of the co-organizers the vo-tech
thanks again for coming out before we
announce our next speaker I just want to
thank everyone who's been on Twitter
tweeting this entire morning
we are like trending on my hyper
personalized feed which is awesome but I
want us to keep doing that and more
importantly there's a startup Columbia
event that's actually happening right
now and they are like ranked number 17
and were ranked number two so I'd like
for us to like continue to be that high
so if you could please keep tweeting
throughout the day share photos etc
that'd be awesome thanks a lot yale Tech
16 cool
so I'd like to introduce our next
speaker Allyson wagon fell
she's the incoming head of marketing for
Google Enterprise which includes the
Google cloud platform Google Apps
Enterprise Google Maps
and the education teams Allyson was
previously an operating partner at
emergence capital where she worked on
investments including text EO handshake
and steel brick and prior to that she
was the executive director of the
Harvard Business School California
Research Center and then prior to that
was actually a co-founder and director
of marketing for Quicken Loans at Intuit
so she spent quite a bit of time in the
valley and has a lot to share
I wasn't graduated from Yale with an
undergrad degree and then did an MBA at
Harvard
so please welcome Allison she's going to
be talking about how to navigate a
career in the technology industry
right on the heels of that and Twitter
announcement now my Twitter is gonna be
trending so so I'm Alison Berkeley wagon
Padma this kind of interesting phase in
my career because this is my one week
off of transition where I am
transitioning from my role at emergence
capital last week and moving into it
this role at Google starting next Monday
so the timing of this conference is
great and what I thought it might be
interesting to talk about is career
trend it just kind of career growth in
general and Silicon Valley because it
it's very different than what I thought
it would be when I was graduating from
Yale and graduating from business school
and talk about some of the different
elements of that and then those be
certainly time for questions and I'll be
here over the course of the day so I'm
not gonna be digging in as much into
venture capital but happy to talk about
that later on or over lunch or anything
like that for those of you that are
raising I'm always happy to help advise
Oh on those lines but as I said I'm
focusing more I'm kind of building a
fulfilling career I need mu can you guys
see it cuz I yeah well I guess you okay
so one of my first kind of key points is
that I found that most careers in
Silicon Valley are very much nonlinear
and this concept of a the corporate
ladder she was really outdated and there
a friend of mine from Yale Laurie Koller
has used the term
the jungle gym is another way of
thinking about it and so I thought I
would walk you through initially some of
my career trends the way it's kind of
gone on and the different transitions
and then talk about some of the guiding
principles that I have seen with others
here at Silicon Valley so I was gonna
actually build this slide but it doesn't
build from here so I'll just walk you
through it starting with the first part
so graduated from Yale in 91 went from
there to Morgan Stanley where I was
investment banking analyst for two years
in New York doing MA and that kind of
day
with bonfire of the vanities and then
went to Hong Kong for a year to work on
financing as a lot of global financings
great opportunity and while I was at
Morgan Stanley I didn't love Investment
Banking but I was a certainly a great
foundation and one of the most
interesting elements of is when I was in
Hong Kong I'm gonna date myself here
halfway through the year they turned on
email for us and that's what happened in
1993 and it completely changed how all
of us worked and suddenly this concept
of doing all-nighters which were so
consistent in banking basically at 8:00
p.m. we would send all of our files to
the analysts in New York who would then
work on them for 12 hours and then send
them back and it had such a fundamental
change in our office and it was this
really eye-opening experience which I
know it just kind of sounds so trivial
now but that how much technology can
change lives and so that has been a
really a guiding principle for me so
when I came back to the states and went
to business school at Harvard Business
School I knew that I wanted to work in
tech and the hard part then was getting
a tech job because all I had in my
resume was Investment Banking so like
any kind of assertive kind of PLA and
HBS the type of person I was like okay
nobody's gonna interview me what do I do
here and when Microsoft came to campus I
did not get on that interview schedule
and then I went at 7 a.m. to the career
services area and knocked on the door or
the guy who was interviewing his name
was rusty Coleman and said if I bring
you lunch will you interview me during
lunch and I think he was a little bit
taken aback and it was kind of like okay
and I ended up going there interviewing
with him during lunch and getting hired
by Microsoft to work that summer in
Reseda men's group which was the MSN
group and that was the summer of Windows
95 the summer of Microsoft's Internet
tidal wave memo things were changing in
the launch of the msn I loved my product
role and I actually enjoyed working at
Microsoft I just didn't want to be in
Seattle so when I graduated I was
looking for roles in the Bay Area I had
a really hard time it was early internet
day is there really hard time figuring
out which what would be a good start up
to go to and whether or not it should
even go to a startup at that point
- you got some advice to go work for a
couple years in a bigger company to
learn more about product management so
that's how I ended up into it and what
was it interesting so I show up it into
it I thought I was gonna work in some of
the new businesses there and I got
assigned to Quicken for Macintosh when
there were like six Mac's being used and
I was literally writing box copy for
like CD ROMs that were then gonna get
like distributed to Costco and I was
like it was such a disconnect and from
when I thought that I was going to be
doing when I arrived in Silicon Valley -
what I was actually doing so I started
canvassing the hallways looking for
other projects that I could do add into
it and I heard through the grapevine
that Scott cook the founder and chair
was looking for someone to basically
think about the mortgage industry and
was there any kind of opportunity for
Intuit to get involved in mortgages and
I raised my hands and said I'd be happy
to look at that of course I had never
gotten a mortgage didn't knew anything
about it but it seemed like an
interesting opportunity so I worked with
the head of TurboTax engineering who was
fantastic based out in San Diego and
with Scott cook and we put together a
business plan for what soon became known
as Quicken Loans and so that was a
really interesting opportunity super
high risk and I'll talk about that a
little bit later to be working on
something I didn't know that much about
and that became we got funded by
essentially the executive group acts
into it but ended up being a phenomenal
experience and Quicken Loans now is this
huge online lender very different than
what we built a ton to it what we had
built was really the front-end part of
it of the online interview and
application area we ended up buying a
call center in the Midwest called Rock
Loans combining them and what eventually
that all spun out of it to it so Quicken
Loans is very much alive and well today
but it actually has very little to do
with Intuit except for the name I think
this Quicken Loans is probably the only
legacy of the name quicken really at
this point because Intuit is actually
sold off those other parts of it but
from that roll once that got spun out
so it was 99 for those of you who are
out here it was just kind of a crazy
time and I couldn't resist the
temptation to go to a start-up at that
point and I was getting calls all the
time and I actually ran into Russell
Minh somewhere against who had since
left Microsoft and ended up as a partner
kleiner perkins and we went and had
lunch somewhere I think at the creamery
in Palo Alto and I said to him like how
do I even navigate what do I think about
what I wear I should go from here
and he said well we're actually
incubating a company within kleiner
perkins an online on a votive company
similar to what I'd been doing with
helping improve the online mortgage
experience I could help reshape with my
vision at least what I thought to help
reshape the car buying experience was
kind of equally broken and so I ended up
joining as the second employee at this
company called green light at the time
it didn't even have a name and working
out a kleiner perkins basement for a
while and then ultimately we can't
accrue that company and then we competed
with this company called cars drift that
had raised something like 300 million
dollars which was just kind of basically
they were giving cars away for free at
that point and we essentially merged
into them in 2001 and that was really
fortuitous timing because unbeknownst to
anybody that was working with I was
actually four months pregnant at the
time and it was a good transition point
to not go move down to LA where cars
direct was and to kind of figure out
where I wanted to go from here and this
is certainly one of the kind of themes
of my career is that different decisions
make different make sense at different
points in time and so at this point my
husband also an HBS grad was running a
technology hedge fund and was traveling
internationally all the time and leaving
the house at you know 5:00 in the
morning each day and we basically
decided that I was I knew I wanted to
keep working but that it wasn't going to
work for me to be in the same kind of 70
hour week a hyper kind of
entrepreneurial path so that's when I
transitioned to the role at HBS running
the California Research Center which I
thought I would do for just a couple of
years and it turns out 10 years later 3
kids later 100 case studies later and a
whole bunch of other really interesting
work there ended up doing that for a
while until essentially late 2012 when I
picked my head up and it knew that was
getting really restless and it was time
for me to get back into something that
had more it's just kind of a more
adrenaline to it and I was just really
missing working with entrepreneurs more
closely as opposed to kind of
chronicling their lives so one of the
board members from the Harvard Business
School a centroid here advisory board
member a good friend of mine Jason green
I was talking to him about what's next
and he suggested that I'd meet with the
rest of the partners and emergence and
they offered me a role to come in and a
newly created role as an operating
partner which was kind of completely
ill-defined it was essentially helped
grow emergences franchise help think
about how this very strong venture firm
that's focused on enterprise cloud
couldn't become that much more
successful and so there's a lot of
different elements of my emergence I was
part of the investment team I made some
new investments but I also was
responsible for all the marketing for
talent and working with all of our
portfolio companies it was a great role
I loved what I was doing and that's what
I assumed until about two months ago
that's what I would be doing for the
rest of my career and then over the
transom in late January early February I
got LinkedIn ping from a recruiter an
executive recruiter at Google that
essentially said would you be open to
talking with Diane green about
enterprise cloud marketing and of course
I've been following Dianna green for
years because she's for those of you
don't know was the founder of VMware
very successful company out here ended
up selling it started a new company
called bebop had been on the board
actually ironically open to it but
Google for four years and was brought in
to Google at the end of last year by
acquiring her company to build out all
of googles Enterprise businesses which
include glue code platform Google Apps
and maps education essentially anything
that Google is doing that sells into
businesses so I was excited to meet with
Diane and seemed like a really great
opportunity and when I assumed was gonna
happen is that she was gonna pick my
brain I'm great Enterprise marketing
people because that's what I've been
working with was 4440 portfolio
companies and it was one of those kind
of different points in time that you
have in your life where you meet someone
and just really click and so we went met
for breakfast that may feel bakery and
again tahno Palo Alto and what was
opposed to be a half-hour breakfast
ended up being almost an hour and a half
two hours later very wide-ranging
conversation from everything about my
background on her background and
Google's opportunity and I was very
frank about what I thought Google from
my perspective was doing well and the
opportunity but also all of the areas of
growth and improvement and she asked me
at the end of breakfast whether I would
be interested in coming over to be the
head of marketing for that area which
really caught me off guard to be honest
I was like wait me and so at first I
said no and I said I love my job I love
what I'm doing at emergence and it
really works in the context of my life
my office is 10 minutes from my house
and I have three kids who are now 10 12
and 14 and I said no and then started
talking with my husband and started
talking with one or two friends who have
known me a long time actually my closest
friend from Yale who's out here
unfortunately not here today and I
remember going for a walk with her that
weekend she also went to HBS with me and
she's like you you have to pursue this
like this is who you are and this is
what you are about and this is what you
wanted to do when you came out of Yale
and what you wanted to do when you came
out of Business School and so how many
kind of reframe a little bit about what
it meant to kind of continue to build a
career at different phases and points of
time and so after kind of Google called
back a week later saying can I you would
you just meet with one or two other
people I said yes at that point and
you know four or five meetings later
about a month or so later Google asked
if I would come over kind of more
officially give me an offer to come over
there and then they're kind of the
hardest decision after the hardest
conversation was then reaching out to my
emergence partners who I think are
fantastic and to actually say to them
you know you're not gonna believe this
but I just got this great opportunity
and I think I'm gonna take it and cut
them completely off-guard but to their
credit they were all so gracious and
they're like that is a really great
opportunity people tell you you should
stay here but like that's what you are
and you should go for it and go do it so
now that's where I kind of am today and
so starting next week we'll be at Google
and the kind of question mark is who
knows where that will go
and so the reason I kind of walk you
through this whole path is because this
is so incredibly nonlinear in terms of
for people who it'll be interesting I
have my 25th Yale reunion this at the
end of this month announced of my 20th
business school reunion and so people
who have not seen me for 20 or 25 years
it may seem like oh this is kind of what
you had wanted to do all along but for
all of those people who have kind of
known me over these last 20 25 years
it's been a pretty circuitous path
actually to then end up on this role at
Google which is actually exactly the
kind of role that I would have imagined
and wanted right when I came out of
particularly out of Business School so
with that context I'm going to share
some guiding principles about kind of
how I've thought about kind of career
navigation for me and then also for
other people that I interact with
because I spend a lot of time talking
about recently with recent graduates
about career growth and what that looks
like and how I've thought about it so
one of the kind of key principles for me
has been always to invest in
relationships in all dimensions of your
life this is a picture of my kids and
the reason I included this photo is that
it turns out that in one of our last ski
trips one of my son goes to school with
the son
of Tony Fadell who's the founder of Nass
who's very involved at Google and ended
up spending a whole day skiing with him
and that was what helped me understand a
little bit more about what Google was
doing in the enterprise and the
different opportunities and has been now
someone I've been able to kind of check
in with and it's only because of
actually being open to meeting the
parents of your kids friends and that I
really truly believe in this concept of
work/life integration and that's not
really about balance it's about kind of
combining everything together and so
that has to do with school networks and
it's certainly Yale and HBS fantastic
networks but my kids school networks and
the soccer sidelines and everything that
they do all the different parts of my
life all bled together I've always been
on nonprofit boards that's always been
an important part of investing in
relationships and things like tennis
games and book clubs and everything like
that so relationships in business it's
they're so far-reaching and it's kind of
incredible to me even in the last few
weeks since I mentioned that I was going
over to Google or how many people from
different parts of my life have reached
out of you know oh you need to meet
so-and-so or can I intro to you to this
person and many of those people are
people that I've known really very
non-work contexts and so that's been
important a second one is seeking out
high visibility projects and also which
are often high risk you know this this
photo is obviously something visibility
high-risk this kind of like I don't
water hoverboard thing I if I had
actually my daughter had actually saved
all the all the photos that would have
been probably the only one cuz all the
other ones were me falling down and the
only ones still on my computer filtered
out but give certainly doing the Quicken
Loans business and - it was a high
visibility high risk to start a new
business right out of like as a 26 year
old at a very successful company is hard
and had it not been successful I'm sure
you know there would be a whole other
set of stories to talk about but I've
also done projects that have definitely
not been successful in other areas when
I was at HBS the research center I spent
a year looking into HBS opening a
classroom and a place out here it
Wharton had just opened up a place in
the city and I put together this
proposal and actually found real estate
right next to 101 the four seasons in
the 101 nose those office buildings
there we had actually like looked at
booking out space there making a
classroom and sent this proposal over
and gave the proposal back to HBS and
they thought about it for a little while
and essentially said no you know we're
not a school that builds classrooms
outside in different parts of the US
we're going to do it in Boston and
totally understood the decision but it
certainly was something that I had
invested a lot in and it got shot down
but what came out of that interestingly
is the next year when Harvard started
building the Harvard Innovation Lab and
I had over the course of doing that one
project about building out here gotten
to know all of these different people at
the University and when it was time to
bill at the Harvard Innovation Lab I
became very involved in that particular
project and everything from the space to
the people to the hiring to the
activities to the programming and that
became a really important part of my
Harvard Business School role for the
last couple of years that I was there
and I don't think I would have ever
gotten so pulled into the iLab projects
without having done the really failed
experiment of building something out
here in the Bay Area so you're just
gonna never know where things are going
to go but when you do these interesting
projects they tend to even when they
fail and I'm sure you guys hear this all
the time they tend to lead to other
things and I've certainly seen that with
friends and colleagues out here this is
a photo of me kind of painfully I'm sure
for this room with it's a whole bunch of
Harvard students and which was one of
the Harvard immersion trips out here one
of the things that we did with the
offices we used to bring all sets of
students anywhere from 24 to 48 students
out here
every winter for a week to do a
entrepreneurship immersion program and I
would love to see yell do something like
this and I've been talking with a lot of
the groups that yell there's so much
good entrepreneurial energy on campus
right now and I know there's a bunch of
people today here from the Yei and
Kyle's here from that so every
entrepreneurship and so it's great that
we're seeing all this energy and I guess
my plea to everybody here would be make
time for all these students when they
come out here because the people in this
room will be the ones who are going to
be pinged somewhere along the way of can
you meet for 15 minutes can you host a
group in your office can you meet some
people for dinner and this is a really
important part of what Silicon Valley is
about and you know hopefully everybody
here does this but I've always found
time for students out here whether it's
been through officially through work or
unofficially and lots of I always invest
time and mentoring I see Joe one of the
people that I've talked to a number of
times here as well that would making
time to help other people for me
particularly helping other women as
something that's really been important
and important for my own growth and
hopefully important for the other people
that I interact with and you know it
doesn't have to be formal it can be very
informal one other thing that I always
do and hopefully everybody else does too
is provide interview feedback you know
we all interview so many people and so
many different times and the massive
vast majority those interviews those
people don't get it hired and I have
found that generally spending five or
ten minutes with people after they don't
get hired to share specifically why and
to give feedback about what cuz people
could do differently I have heard from
many many people just how impactful that
has been because most people give the
kind of platitude I'm sorry it wasn't a
good fit and there's so many reasons why
something's not that kind of quote good
fit and often a lot of those are very
changeable and future interviews it's
just the way the person has presented
themselves and they actually could have
been a good fit and it's almost more of
a personal marketing so making time to
do that for other people or if you're
ever interviewing and asking for that
feedback I think is really valuable
another accounting principle I've seen
for
everyone out here and this probably goes
without saying for a group of jelly's
but this kind of constant intense
curiosity is what drives so many people
here and some of the most successful
people I've seen and the most fulfilled
are those that have really followed that
curiosity who dig deep asks the second
third and fourth question and then go
home and research further and then ask
you know fifth sixth seventh eighth
ninth question it's you know finding
something that you know why was the
Google AI able to beat the go player
this time while asking why and what is
what's happening differently now and how
did that work differently this time and
being able to kind of go deep is
something that's I really just
appreciated with the people out here and
particularly I think that Yale is more
than almost any other people that I know
do this naturally and it's one of the
reasons why I love spending so much time
with Yale grads and then finally this is
one of my favorite quotes and it's
practice isn't the thing you do once
you're good it's the thing that makes
you good and it's something that and I'm
so yeah there's a little bit of a
culture of just kind of winging it and
while it's great to be able to wing it
in different situations I think that
routinely and this may be more true
sadly for women than for men out here
but kind of practicing and kind of going
ahead and role play even when I was
interviewing with emergence and I got an
offer and I was gonna ask for more money
because that's what you know
particularly women don't do and should
do every time they get an offer for
anything and I role played with my
friend from Yale and said like okay this
is what I'm gonna say and she's you had
background and she's like well this is
what they're gonna say it's like okay
well then this is what I'm gonna say and
I kind of role-playing it a few times
makes it easier to actually do and those
are all just different forms of practice
and I have found over the years that you
know if you have a partner or spouse
that you can practice with or you have
friends or some people have forums like
YPO forums at other types of forums but
finding groups of people or friends in
this room or whoever it is to be able to
share your ideas and
play it now I have found to be very
valuable so in summary we share a couple
final thoughts and then hopefully we
have time for some questions if you want
them either as a group or in smaller
groups later certainly first one is the
Career Planning is so much different
than what I thought it was I don't know
why when I graduated from school I just
assumed that everything was so linear
and that like if I go to work sailing I
don't know I assumed then then I would
just go on to become a managing director
of Morgan Stanley and then my next job I
assumed that I would just keep growing
there and it doesn't really work that
way it really doesn't work that way in
tech it certainly doesn't work that way
in the context of having a family and
having different points in time when
there's different levels of intensity
that work in the context of growth as in
the broader in life and have found that
having these guiding principles has
really helped me navigate and others
that I know navigate that kind of twists
and turns that are appropriate and that
just happened in the context of career
building another one certainly keeping
in touch with people and keeping doors
open it certainly happens it's easier to
do now with LinkedIn and with Facebook
and with others and it's part of what
going to reunions is all about and it's
part of what going to events like this
is all about but making the time first
submit not just the the technical
connections on Facebook personal
connections to stay in touch has really
been valuable it's it's not accidental
that Russ siegelman hired me at
Microsoft then was helpful with me and
essentially hired me for the kleiner
perkins startup that I did greenlight
and then has been a mentor and a step
every step along the way in all of the
different decisions we we've checked it
and he's always been a really great
sounding board and so having those
people and staying in touch with them is
really important and along those lines
remembering to thank the people that
helped you it's it seems so obvious but
it's so rarely done and making the time
to the
no sometimes even a personal note is
really nice but just to say thank you
because all of us have gotten to where
we are in our careers because other
people have probably looked out for us
along the way and taking that time to
say thank you for it and finally the
last one is if you do good work great
things happen and they don't always
happen at the time that you think that
they are going to and so as I when this
Google offer came in over the transom
essentially what certainly wasn't
looking for it but it was from years of
investing in relationships and investing
in skills and I'm sure I was back
channel to every which way to Sunday and
so you you know every we all get back
channeled for everything that we do and
you never really know when that's gonna
happen and so the consistent the best
thing we all could do of course is
consistently do great work and then from
that all great things so with that happy
to open it up for questions and we can
go for their talk about how you had this
yearning to lean into it join us start
up I'm just curious if like he's still
kind of out there earning and if you
weren't a target of Duke
won't be some kind of the main
characteristics it's interesting because
it's always I Google is an enormous
company but in some ways I'm going to
one of the more entrepreneurial
businesses there because Google's
opportunity in the enterprise is pretty
new everything that it's done so far has
really been consumer and advertising
related and now selling into enterprises
is in competing and not being number one
Google's been number one for so long but
not number one with a Google cloud
platform competing with AWS and not
number one a Productivity the Google
apps business competing with Microsoft
so some of the startup elements that I
love I will have there but it certainly
doesn't have the whole resource
constraints components and I have always
kind of gone back and forth a little bit
between that because certainly and
Intuit it was that a big company but
Quicken Loans was a start-up we were
very much resource constrained to build
that and then when I went to green light
it was you know me in a room and you
know begging for free food from kind of
her guns and that everything was about a
constraint and you make very different
decisions then and one of the roles that
emergence was working with 40-plus
startups about you who are all were
living in a resource-constrained world
and so there's never been tested for me
though as much as I worked with all
those startups from emergence I didn't
have that kind of yearning to jump into
any particular one of them there'd be
times when I'd be like oh that would be
such a fun role or that would be really
interesting when we made the investment
in CrunchBase for example that was
really interesting we looking for a new
CEO and I was thinking oh that's a
really interesting role but it wasn't
interesting enough that I ever like did
anything about it
so for some reason different jobs and I
found this along it kind of catch your
fancy at different points in time and
it's hard to know exactly why and as
what I put Google and then question mark
who knows where I'll go from here but
there's something particularly exciting
about being part of a startup
that core group and you know Lee and I
just talk through it and others have to
that is magical so if you haven't done
it here you want to do it it's worth
doing that as part of a career growth
let's go there I'm not sure Yael really
teaches and I'm wondering if you can
reflect on at all is especially for
young women if you realize early in your
career you're in a place where you're
not getting the risky or high exposure
project projects how to actually can you
reflect more about what walking in the
halls entails and take a little more
into how we might be able to teach young
women to do that yes so I'll take it in
two parts one is kind of what did it
actually entail it entailed proactively
meeting with all the people that
interviewed me when you go work for
companies you often get interviewed by
different people in different groups and
then you sometimes never talk to those
people again because even you end up in
one kind of very defined group and so
for me what it was was the will let me
go back to all these people that kind of
interviewed me in it to it and sold to
me I'm going there and say to them this
isn't what I had in mind and what do you
think I could do what are some ideas and
so I probably put feelers out to maybe
10 or 15 different people and not saying
that like oh I hate my manager I'm
really unhappy it was more that I really
want to work on something
entrepreneurial and using the new
internet technology and can you help me
be on the lookout for to potential
opportunities what the way it actually
rolled out though is there was a person
who was a VP I guess in our group who
was aware it was one of the many people
that I talked to and for about four
months I worked two jobs there so I
nights and weekends was writing the
quicken mortgage business plan and
during the daytime I was doing the
Quicken for Mac cd-rom business
and it took a long time and a fair
amount of patience actually to do both
of these things and have a conviction
that what I really wanted to do this
more entrepreneurial endeavor would
actually get some funding and would be
able to go forward and patience was
probably the hardest part for me then
because I it's still probably a lot of
us have issues with patience but it's
certainly coming out at 26 at business
school I was ready to get going and I
felt like the internet was happening
around me and why was it taking so long
but it was through that experience of
sticking with it and I was cold calling
lenders I was doing whatever it took and
that was valuable so in terms of broader
advice for you said young women coming
out of Yale because young people in
general it goes to the point of keeping
networks broad and having lots of
different relationships and asking lots
of questions and asking people how can I
help you and for that a lot of what I
was doing at Intuit then was it to and
wants to become a more modern internet
company what does that look like and how
can I help and not saying you know can
you help me and when you start by asking
how can I help you
lots more doors tend to open and I think
that that's probably what I would the
advice that I would give thank you this
is really interesting I have a hard time
picking a follow-up question but I think
I have a good one I had a I had a I work
for VMware som graduate and in product
marketing so I had a lot of trouble
picking what to do in my career almost
for as long as I can remember so your
math is interesting but one thing that
broke my confusion little was at HBS
professor Deepak Malhotra who had
dressed into 2012 class and his quote
was quit often quitting early and he
used that mantra to treat to quit often
quit early and often quit early
something like that
do you ever hear that or what does that
mean to you I know what it means to me
is if you don't like something don't sit
in it for too long take action make a
change before you get maybe too negative
yeah I haven't heard that it's I think
that in some ways mine too experience
was an example of that but it was
probably a softer gentler example of
rather than quitting and telling my boss
I'm not gonna do this quicken job it was
finding an alternative but I did that
maybe two or three months into my job so
that would fall into the early category
for sure I knew that that wasn't where I
wanted to be from that point on though
I've been really fortunate and I've had
great roles with great bosses and so for
me that hasn't resonated the only other
time I think I came up is the Harvard
Business School role that I was in I was
in that for a decade and that was much
longer than I planned to be in that and
for a whole variety of experience if her
reasons
you know family related work-related
health related a whole bunch of things I
ended up staying in that role and it
there was rarely a time when I really
felt like quitting but when I knew in
2012 that it was time I got on it and so
sometimes as soon as you have that
inkling and you know that something's
not working that would be there kind of
often in early it's not it's not so much
often but it makes the change because
rarely does it get better on its own
without doing something quit as a little
extreme but the transition from James
one of your recommendations was to read
a lot so what has had the most at the
most impact on you or a few things that
you read regularly that you think are
really worth reading so lately I've
become a little bit of a medium addict
to be honest and I don't know if you any
of you guys have used medium is a great
publishing platform that a lot of
individuals post on and I there kind of
almost bite-sized reads it says at the
top of each of them actually how long it
will take to read it usually four or
five minutes or something like that I
have found myself in the evenings
working with
my way through a number of medium posts
and the platform does an interesting job
of if you like this you might like that
where I might go down the rabbit hole
and some artificial intelligence area
that I would not necessarily have done
three articles later so I tend to read a
lot there I tend to read I tend to read
a reasonable number of business books
but not all of the books I'll read a
little bit in the beginning and a little
bit there and rarely do I read a whole
business book cover-to-cover I listen a
lot to podcasting this actually one of
the elements it's a bummer that I'm
gonna have a commute now going from the
mid Peninsula down to Mountain View but
the flipside is that a half hour will be
an opportunity to listen so I really
enjoy listening and more than reading
books I tend to listen tip books I also
find it helpful on from just staying on
top of news I use something called
nuzzle and noozle and nuzzle prompts all
the things that people in my network are
reading and so I can stay abreast what
others are doing and noozle is when
somebody in my network is involved in
something so I like I used both of those
tools and I find them helpful and I
actually find it interesting on Facebook
to see what other people recommend
questions on the topic of transition for
anyone who may be considering
transitions considering that the advices
to do it often what are you doing to
prepare for your transition to Google so
that's a tough it's a good question a
tough question because I'd won and I
know that I'm gonna be drinking from
this firehose starting next Monday so
there was only so much that I should be
doing in advance of that because I gonna
be so all-in and this is my one week and
so as I've been like tempted to start
reading and doing more and meet with
people I keep how actually holding
myself back because I know I will
that's essentially I'll be all in what I
have done is I've certainly
red I've talked to a number of people
that I know who are working with Google
in one way or another on the enterprise
side so people in our portfolio
companies people that I just happened to
know in my network and asking what their
perceptions are because because I have a
marketing role a lot of it is
understanding what people think about
Google and its enterprise offering today
and where we need to bring it to and so
I've been doing a lot of asking
questions and listening and reading what
the there's various news articles what
some of the equity analysts are writing
and getting a baseline essentially and
so that's been nice in some ways I think
the most important part of my transition
that and trying to learn more about the
team will be inheriting a great team of
a number of different people around the
world and learning more about their
backgrounds and interests in what drives
them so that from day one we can have a
great working relationship
what's been the two main areas also